it was probably the Vape This is how
much trouble he got in he walked in the
last day of school he walked into the
house he was 15 he put his backpack down
he walked into his room he didn't come
out till
September that happened freshman year
and Senior year no Xbox no PlayStation
no going outside he can go in the
backyard but dude it was know the he was
like a free range chicken back there do
you know do you know what the biggest
the yard and like he was in prison like
do you know what the biggest move about
that buz though you would he left all my
electronics in there he left the Xbox he
left the TV he left anything that I
would like to use he just took all the
power cords so I'm just sitting
there staring at everything like turn on
God damn it Like H drove myself crazy
for summer it was awful Beth said to me
she goes you going to bring the you
going to get the uh the Xbox I go nah
she goes why not I go I'm just taking
the cords she goes why I go I just wish
I was in there when he realized he
didn't have any cords